[Music]
even with the kills even because the
fight was so close to cloud9 space this
could be the
end of the series this could be it team
solomid
looking to dethrone cloud9 as the north
american champion
nobody gets second places like cloud9
get second places
they are the only team to lift the
trophy
back to back to back to
back and they are the best
was really in a bad state and broken i
mean pretty much it just seemed like
there were some people that
didn't want to play with me anymore most
moves made so far i believe
from the uh returning lcs franchises
cloud9 well internally like we knew this
team was going to crush it
ben follows up on it santorum's just
trying to hobble out
he's not back here so c9 says what oh
my teammates are going to go for this
game
and it's actually going to be an
eventual three towers off of this play
and potentially honey getting dope
not the best oak flag oh bounce still by
vulcan kites sideways
can't get away licorice temporarily
actually has glove lead he's five first
fence gear this is gonna come on the
backhand side kubo double knock
he's certainly trying to damage his old
teammate but it's not gonna be enough
because this
is why you're on the academy team
these days licorice is north america's
best top laner
he is a champion who led c9 to their
first victory
in six years but just a few months ago
everyone was calling him a traitor
licorice joined c9 ahead of the 2018
season he was replacing impact a former
world champion so
he had some pretty big shoes to fill
like when we when we
brought like licorice up uh to replace
impact we got a ton of [ __ ]
but the thing is is every week we were
scrimming against eu united
and we saw like we saw frankly we saw
the chris dumpstering impact
in licorice's first year with the team
c9 had their best worlds performance
ever
making it all the way to the semi-finals
they do not
want the heart oh they're going for it
oh what a hook by tucson they're gonna
find the way in though the orange gonna
come across
and the knock-ups are there is this the
fight
it's two for zero and the guardian
angels are pumped
this could well be it look at them clean
up the map
and the last vestige of korea has been
destroyed
cloud nine will make it to the
semifinals
a three zero sweep the first time
in seven years cloud nine
in the top four at worlds
but just a year later c9 got bopped
harder than they had in
years right now griffin are just forcing
in the top lane
tower the inhib tower will fall they're
now looking for the inhibitor
you can see sword is down towards the
bottom side of this keep english
licorice busy
here comes the paranoia the one punch
has been thrown by c9 but they really
don't have the damage to take down
anyone
griffin the hands still alive fight for
them as well they just clean them up
you can't even cast this it is
disgusting to watch
dirty stuff from griffin no response
from cloud9
and griffin just slammed through the
door they break down the wall they break
down the defenses of c9
and they lay a stake on a spot in the
quarter-finals after a devastating loss
against team liquid in the 2019 summer
finals and a disappointing run at worlds
fans knew changes were coming after we
were eliminated from worlds and i
started having the
you know post season interviews with all
the with all the players
um that's when i knew that the
extent of the changes were going to be
larger than i
may have originally anticipated because
it was clear that about half the members
no longer wanted to play with each other
c9 replaced three of the five players
from their starting lineup
sven skarin zazel and fan favorite ad
carey
sneaky we don't exactly know why it's
not working on bot lane but we know
we don't like it and we need to move
away from you like
that's a shitty message to send on like
because people want to know why
and i didn't have a real clear like this
this this this it was just like the
whole thing ain't working we tried to
fix it for a year and
we need to move try something completely
different that that
um was very painful to pass on
um and very personal and um i don't want
to ever do it again unfortunately it's
part of my job
for long time c9 fans sneaky's departure
was especially bad
he was more than just the most popular
player on the team he was the soul of c9
he'd been playing with them for seven
years and he was the last remaining
member of their legendary debut
lcs roster fans were disappointed but
one sneaky told his side of the story
that disappointment
turned to anger i mean pretty much it
just seemed like
there were some people that
didn't want to play with me anymore
it was not only me it was the bot lane
like they wanted a new bot lane
sneaky's comment started a witch hunt in
the community people were desperate to
find out who didn't want to play with
him
eventually they gathered their
pitchforks and went after licorice
using a specific moment from worlds as
evidence i mean it was going well until
we got the baron and then
um we got caught mid when i was like
too far to have any split pressure so we
had to like team fight and then the team
i did
looking for it here as the devour is you
sneaky flashes away
but importantly he is still alive viper
lingers there
he's so lucky he's yeah he's gonna dive
into the back of the fight tarzan goes
down low but the fiora is dead the sonar
dice as well griffin may have found it
three kills now
i mean it's gonna be weird talk about
the game without a replay but yeah
if you guys can't be safe men with like
tom soda i just don't know how to play
the game
the community was merciless they called
licorice a traitor they demanded he
apologized to sneaky they flooded his
tweets with snake emojis
i don't know why um he took
more i mean i took my share of flame but
it was really weird
that he was he was getting a lot of
flame when
you know he isn't the guy telling sneaky
hey you're not going to be part of this
team
it was me and um so i it was really it
was
really unfair that he got hit with that
and after getting slammed with hate for
days
licorice went on stream to address the
rumors like we just had like differing
opinions
on stuff like that and it just didn't
seem like it was that resolvable
so at the end of the year um
like they came and talked to me and i
was like hey like these are some of the
problems i'm seeing and i definitely
like want to see some things to
change for like next year and like i
knew that could mean
like people get removed i knew that
could mean i got removed but losing
sneaky wasn't the only issue c9 fans had
they were also losing their beloved
support zazel and reigning
mvp jungler svenskaran and to make
matters worse
fans were not thrilled with the
replacement losing sneaky was bad enough
but his replacement
zven was having a pretty shitty 2019.
a fight that goes the right way will
push people down the question is can
they find
those margins can they find that opening
so far tsm has outmaneuvered
quick silver sash he is down
the new jungler blabber was considered a
coin foot player
and vulcan the support was kind of a
nobody who vince didn't think was worth
the 1.75
million dollars c9 paid for him but at
what point did he become like
so much more valuable than zeisel's
smoothie bio frost core jj like what
like
is he is he better than any of those
people i just mentioned i've put him
like in the same tier as
as met some of them maybe zazel's a
little bit worse based off summer
performance but like
i just don't know if he's worth the
money like i would i would have liked to
see like what they
could have done if they just spent that
money trying to get like a different 80k
while the organization was confident in
the new roster the fans pretty much all
agreed
c9 lost the off-season outside of like
the
outside of uh our team
and outside of most pros opinions people
thought we just
another lost offseason terrible roster
decisions what the hell are you doing
but licorice had heard that one before
when he joined the team back in 2018
c9 also lost the offseason but they made
it all the way to world semi-finals
this time though things were different
after all that sneaky drama
all eyes were on a licorice and there
was only one way to silence the haters
and keep his reputation intact
win four notes does not find that
engaged though
and now comes the re-engaged four target
ultimate big knock up there keith is
gonna go down
flash supports get away and now licorice
on the side as well lacrosse gets away
from the cage
now both of the front lines still they
find another record going on a good way
out a double kill for the jungler but
third one picks up as well in the back
line they go they are cleaning house
with a single death the buzz light ace
is in there for cloud nine
and barrett is there for the taking
remember you could always have the smite
fight
i think this is one that you always risk
if your dignitas
rig thinking about it gangplank ulti
already summoned up cloud9 playing this
slowly
very nice shot wave on the two and
froggen
gets the first kill of the split on to
spin but
at what cost dignitas
is annihilated by cloud9
sm have four guys here already
cloud9 can see that shelly taken down to
3000 hp now a little bit more damage and
a proc of the eyes gonna do it nice
bullet time from tsm vulcan using the
stasis to buy a little bit of time
broken blade nearly gonna be killed
nisky now having to use the ultimate
defensively vulcan once again
barely kept alive biofrost going into a
stasis of his own
dardoch's not able to find the kill just
yet nisty grabbing the kill on the
biofrost
and cloud9 have navigated this fight
just beautifully bjergsen stands alone
1v5 how do they keep getting away with
it cloud9
just take everything cloud9
bulldozed the spring split going 17 and
1
in what is now considered one of the
most dominant regular season
performances in lcs
history but then you arrive here at the
first and final all-pro team and i don't
think it will
come as much as a pr of a surprise to
anyone that all five cloud nine members
uh
occupy the spots here no one expected
this roster to be as good as they were
turned out that this team of misfits was
a team of
monsters blabber became the league mvp
by being a jungle bully
slapping down his opponents with a
disgustingly aggressive playstyle
nisky rose to the top of na's mid lane
by taking a page from the reigning world
champion doing b's book
and roaming to get his other teammates
ahead freed from the shackles of tsm
zavan was back in classic eu form
and vulcan the 1.75 million dollar
support
proved he was worth every penny and
somehow
licorice still stood out among this team
of monsters
despite getting less resources than
every other member of the team
he crushed top lane every single game
he became the team's rock someday
doesn't actually get the auto attack off
he needs to get the healing finally gets
that out of down now
nice oh juke's the third q here comes
centault over the top for the shields
and the dodge the damage
but can he get away there comes the
second stun and licorice
takes the kill but the regular season
was never c9's problem
the issues always started in the
playoffs
yeah the thing is like if you're looking
at our just our scrim records like over
the last several years
you would see we're winning something
like you know at least 80
of the games um through the first 90
of the season and then you would see
this stark difference in playoffs where
the players like we were certainly like
50 50 or worse
and um but in every single time you
think back in history like oh yeah they
started playing some wow expansion oh
yeah path of exile was a thing
oh yeah they're playing fortnite like um
there was always like this
this lack of focus like like once we
checked off the box we're going to
playoffs
all steam was lost and and we had to
identify
what was causing that there's multiple
reasons and this stamp was out
but this c9 was different but meteos is
able to finally grab a kill here for 100
thieves on the top side
and this key looking to chase even
further good god
two for what deal very end of the paddle
star
buy one get one free
triple kill for nisky he's been looking
for the final mystic shot to take down
the enemy jungler blabbers coming in
he's got the umi right on top of him
there's the roots there's the engage
there's the team fight
there's the potential counter-attack but
not so fast
here come the thundering hooves from
behind and the hecarim
arrives it's cody son of someday heading
for the hill
as nisky jumps up the wall and ben is
there to go
unstoppable and break down someday uh
might actually get something done
licorice has no flash as you can see
for the play eq one more auto will kill
him no
with the slimmest of margins at what
point can he
defend 3v5 and that point is never
they're going to try with their fourth
member as kumo comes in they're going to
do their very best they knock back one
they hope to find some kind of a team
fight is kumo frontline sequence over
the top is going to find bangs spit back
out the rest of the squad respawns
they've got all five and they're gonna
try it's gonna be valiant but it's not
gonna be enough
three quick kills picked up cloud nine
gonna complete the best of five
they're gonna take they wanna texas and
secure that ticket
into finals there is the darkness there
is now flyquest not knowing what's going
on this side of the map there's the hook
in the front line there's the box they
play back
solo and here comes the engage yet again
stop watching for another blabbern ski
is already in the back line fights
santorum who jumps away and stays alive
the flag represents the first kill the
second one goes over to his top laner
and that wind ball was perfect it blocks
everything from poe a double kill for
the jungler double kill for the top
laner there's the kills coming through
fast and furious
the bar light ace for cloud9 they will
not go for the dragon they will go for
the nexus
solo is the only thing standing in the
way of cloud9 lifting the trophy and
it's not going to be enough
he's trying to stall as much as possible
he's got respawns in 10 seconds tanky
man redemption helps build the time
though and that's his ski on a rampage
santorini's back alive the nexus turrets
are going to fall
centroid goes for minions then back to
the engage the bot lanes are
alive in five seconds but they will not
stop it
cloud nine waited six years and they
will hoist the trophy again
for all five players the first time in
their careers
the nexus falls licorice deals the
killing blow
and cloud9 when the 2020 lcs spring
split
after 2191 days
five players who had never won an lcs
title before
ended c9 six year championship drought
after six years of not getting there and
then finally getting it
especially with a team that like with my
own blood sweat tears and 1.75 million
in buyouts recently
like a cheetah achieve a victory felt
really good at the beginning of the
split
everyone called licorice a traitor but
by the end of it
he forced them to call him a champion
and he didn't talk the haters down
he just played so well that they
couldn't hate him anymore
yeah it's been really exciting for him
to
get positive recognition now especially
after getting
a lot of negativity and it's well
deserved i want to be a team that can
beat anybody and i think that this
could be a team that can beat anybody
and i think that's what a real
or not like a real but like what a
world's run that i would feel really
great about at this point
would look like
i really hate this script by now malcolm
did a great job there's a fantastic
script but i've just i've read it so
many times now that i'm losing my mind i
know how andrew feels when he's like
i've watched this video eight times
today
i've read this script [ __ ] eight
times in the last two days